dans l'histoire du crime les États-Unis
battent souvent de tristes record en
voici encore un la police Dieu Milwaukee
vient de découvrir un véritable charnier
dans l'appartement d'un ouvrier 18 corps
les enquêteurs ont mis fin au massacre
parce qu'une victime a échappé in
extremis au coup de couteau de la sasa
manuel saint Paul ça fait 8 mois que ça
pue ici
à plusieurs reprises et locataires de
cet immeuble de Milwaukee c'était plein
aux propriétaires des bruits de scie
électrique au milieu de la nuit une
nauséabonde odeur de chair en
décomposition une infection de mouches
lorsque les policiers ont franchi la
porte de l'appartement suspect il ne
pensait pas mettre les pieds dans un
charnier
tout ce que nous pouvons dire c'est
qu'il s'agit d'homicide demeurent en
série Jeffrey dammeur employé dans une
chocolaterie était réputée pour sa
discrétion et sa courtoisie dans son
deux pièces les enquêteurs ont retrouvé
une dizaine de cadavres mutilés les
victimes sont des hommes apparemment
attirés sur place dans l'espoir d'une
aventure homosexuelle victime du
cannibale ils en sont ressortis en
morceaux sur la liste d'un macabre
inventaire trois têtes dans un
réfrigérateur des parties génitales dans
une boîte à chaussures le reste dans un
grand baril d'acide aux États-Unis Drey
dramer a été condamné 15 fois à la
réclusion criminelle à perpétuité ce
siriol killer se tuer hors-série et en
série avait avoué le meurtre d'au moins
15 personnes il a été jugé sain d'esprit
avant d'entendre sa condamnation il
avait demandé pardon aux familles de ces
15 victimes Maryse Burgaud
la colère la détresse d'une femme face à
l'assassin de son fils lui reste
impassible comme si depuis le début ce
procès n'était pas le sien le verdict
est pourtant ce soir sans ambiguïté la
perpétuité pour Jeffrey Dahmer et pour
chacun de ces 15 crimes calmement celui
qu'on appelle le tueur de Milwaukee
s'explique une dernière fois
j'ai fait ce que j'ai fait non pour des
raisons de haine je ne hais personne je
crois que j'étais malade au fou où les
deux je crois vraiment que je suis
malade les médecins m'ont parlé de cette
maladie maintenant je suis en paix
Jeffrey Dahmer ou l'histoire d'un enfer
imaginé par un meurtrier maniaque et
tortionnaire dans cet appartement 15
jeunes hommes ont trouvé la mort tous
mutilés torturé violet assassiné dépecé
un cauchemar macabre mise en scène par
un homme à l'apparence banale en fait en
trois semaines de procès Jeffrey Dahmer
a donné l'image d'un meurtrier froid et
calculateur machiavélique au point
d'installer dans son appartement un
système de verrou magnétique
lorsqu'elles avaient passé la porte de
son ancre ses victimes étaient
irrémédiablement piégées ces victimes
souvent de jeunes homosexuels toujours
de couleur noire il voulait t'en faire
ses esclaves quand les policiers
découvrent l'appartement de dameurs en
juillet dernier il trouve des restes
humains dans le réfrigérateur des
membres conservés dans des tonneaux
d'acide des gestes qui selon les jurés
étaient totalement réfléchis ils n'ont
pas retenu la thèse de la démence
plaidée par la défense
Jeffrey Dammer a été assassiné dans sa
prison américaine du Wisconsin où il
était emprisonné pour avis pour avoir
lui-même tué 17 personnes ce malade
avait fait la une de l'actualité aux
États-Unis on avait en effet découvert
qu'il se comportait comme un cannibale à
l'égard de la plupart de ses victimes
Maryse bureaux
chez les détenus c'est une sorte de côte
d'honneur il y a les crimes nobles et
les autres c'est comme ça dans toutes
les prisons du monde tout homme condamné
pour crime sexuel et banni détesté par
ses codes détenus Jeffrey Dahmer n'a pas
échappé à la règle il était l'un des
plus célèbres tueurs en série hier matin
son corps est retrouvé dans une salle de
bain de la prison de portage aux
États-Unis exécuté accoud de manche à
balai
violence à la mesure des crimes
perpétrés par Jeffrey dammeur arrêté en
91 il avouait le meurtre de 17 jeunes
garçons et détaillaient ses crimes il
violait et manger ses victimes lorsque
les policiers perquisitionnent sont
domicile c'est une véritable boucherie
qu'il découvre un an plus tard celui
qu'on appelle le boucher du Milwaukee
est condamné à la prison à vie une fois
déjà dans sa cellule on avait essayé de
le tuer cette fois Jeffrey Dahmer n'a
pas échappé au code d'honneur des
détenus
[Musique]